By now you've seen a few different examples of composite functions. And for one
pair of functions we found both, f composed with g, and g composed with f. What
I'm wondering is if order matters. Does it matter if f is the outer function
and g is the inner function, or vice versa? In other words is the output of
these two composite functions the same. Well we're going to test that for a
bunch of different pairs of functions. In the first column over here, we have
what I'm going to call function one. And over here function two. For each pair,
please find f of g and then g of f. And then pick whether or not they're the
same. Now I know that for some of these it doesn't actually look like we're
doing any math. These bottom three functions are all modeling real life
situations. But we can still think of them as functions. They all produce a
certain outcome and I'm wondering if the order we do these actions in, changes
the final outcome of the situation. So, f of g, for this first case here, where
f is putting on left shoe, and g is putting on your right shoe, would mean
putting on your right shoe and then putting on your left shoe. Whereas g of f,
would be putting on your left shoe, and then putting on your right shoe. So
again, just consider if the order we apply either of these functions in,
affects the end situation.